الى اي درجه
الشارع اليوم يختلف في احيائه لذكرى
الثوره عن الاعوام الفائته
[تصفيق]
الشارع اليومي صحيح ان الحشد ليس بتابعه
يعني عشرات الالاف او بالمليونيه لكنه حشد
معقول ومحترم وفي كثير من الحساسيات
موجوده جبهه الخلاص الوطني حركه النهضه
موجوده ايضا اليسار ومنذ قليل كان السيد
محمد هنيني يخطب امام جمهوره امام المسرح
الوطني
[تصفيق]
[ضحك]
2012/2013 14 15 16 الى انحرفت ال- ال-
المسارات في السنوات الاخيره اصبح يوم
احياء يوم 14
يوم الاحتفالات صحيح بدات تعود للتنوع
يعني المشاركات
للعديده والمكثفه لكنها تحمل طابعا طرح
احتجاجيا موجهها ضد رئيس الدوله والشعارات
التي ترفع من نوع دجاج وارحل ارحل ويسقط
الصعيد وغيرها كلها موجهه ضد رئيس الدوله
على عكس السنوات الفارسه ربما التي كانت
نجد فيها انواع من ربما مطالب اخرى
ومواجهه ضد اطراف عديده لكن ما يجمع كل
هذه المنظمات هذا العام هو الاحتجاج على
مساله همم الاجتماعيه
همم الخطاب مباشره الى رئيس الجمهوريه
ومطالبته
نور الدين همم امين همم الاتحاد الشغل
تحدث عن الاستعداد لمعركه وطنيه من اجل
انقاذ تونس همم هل لك ان تفسر لنا همم
المعاني التي قصدها من وراءها الحديث عن
معركه وطنيه لانقاذ تونس
حتى في احدى الخطابات قبل هذا الخطاب في
بيجه تقريبا منذ 20 يوم قال اننا سننزل
الى
الشوارعسم بها لكن يبدو ان الاتحاد العام
التونسي للسلم لم يحسم امره بعد في خصوص
قرار المواجهه مع النظام لانزال يرغب في
الحوار والمقصود من كلمه التبوي معركه
وطنيه يقسم الاقتناء على الرباعي او
التحالف الرباعي بينه وبين ربه
الاجتماعي ولا في حدا اكثر اوراق كامله في
كل ما يتعلق به اصلاح الاوضاع السياسيه
الاجتماعيه وقانونيه وبالتالي لا اعتقد ان
ما عرفته همم المقصود بها هو العنف او
المواجهه في الشوارع لم يكن الى هذه
الدرجه بعد ما زال يؤمن بالحوار وما زال
يمد يديه الى الحوار لكن المشكله هي ان
رئيس الدوله وبين كل اشكال الحوار وحتى
بالامس لما يعني وقعت الموافقه على هذه
التظاهرات نزل قبلهم الى شارع بورفيده
واعاده التحدي من جديد واعاده نفس الاوصاف
للتخوين وبغير ذلك وبالتالي تبدي ارضيه
الحوار ما زالت سعيده في المنام وما زالت
معركه الاتحاد وغير الاتحاد طويله سواء
فيما يتعلق بالاصلاح همم والحوار او ما
يتعلقوا بالمواجهه والشارع